but first we are less than one day away
from sippy cup
meeting with vladimir putin and tonight
ahead of the summit
well putin is trashing the u.s openly
laughing at joe biden
vladimir putin he is a hostile actor and
joe was right he's a murderer he runs
his country like a massive crime
syndicate
not like joe and hunter and joe's
brother
the biden family syndicate except a
little more ruthless
anyway like most organized criminals
vladimir
only responds to strength he doesn't
respond to weakness
and so obviously he doesn't respect or
fear president sippy cup why should he
now under biden the era of peace through
strength is over
american first policies have now been
replaced with american dead last
policies
just last month russia hackers they
wreaked
literally wrecked america's oil and gas
supply joe
inexplicably that rewards putin
lifting sanctions and giving a waiver to
putin for russia to build a pipeline
so they can supply the lifeblood of our
western european allies energy
biden's appeasement strategy is not the
only thing at play here
during joe's trip abroad the entire
world seeing firsthand
how weak how frail how confused what a
cognitive struggling mess joe really is
one sky news australia host actually
raising concerns about quote
joe biden's mental capacity after this
video emerged showing joe aimlessly
wandering around a cafe
in england well to be rescued by jill
biden
one new york post headline read quote
bumbling biden's g7
nato summit performance only boosts
u.s euro foes another headline reads
more evidence joe biden is just not well
true to form
today joe got completely confused
mid-sentence during a meeting
i don't know what to even tell you that
he's trying to say here
i'll let you decipher take a look
europe is uh is our our
natural partner and the reason is we're
committed to the same democratic norms
and institutions
that are and they are increasingly under
attack
and we i've said before and i apologize
to repeat oh i didn't that's jake
sullivan you know jake is my nasa screen
advisor
i'm leaving out a lot of people here i
apologize i'm going to get in trouble
but
anyway we'll get back to that but um
we um uh you know
there's a lot that uh that
is is is happening
okay why does the president of the
united states constantly
live in a state of fear he's going to
get in trouble joey
sippy cup you're the president i need to
remind you every hour of every day i'll
be glad too
this trip has been an utter train wreck
frankly i find it embarrassing
and it's all that dr first lady jill
biden can do to try and keep joey in
line take a look
you can sit down
i don't want you to stand through it
joe pay attention
how are your meetings going in cornwall
mr president
how are your meetings going here in
cornwall very well come on
joey pay attention
okay joe you're the president you don't
need permission
and you got to focus as president if you
try really hard you might do better
but don't worry i'm sure tomorrow's
meeting with the
hostile regime thug of russia known as
vladimir putin
oh i'm sure this is just going to go
great and in case you need more evidence
to decide whether or not
joe is up to the task we report we let
you
decipher for yourself take a look
vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you had
called him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he is
a killer
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was uh
there are certain things that he would
do or did do
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand
four one what's with the ten-second
pause
the world is watching this mess and by
the way joe biden was
oh three hours late to that presser
where he answered questions from just
five pre-approved reporters we have no
idea
joe was three hours late they won't give
us an answer i don't know
maybe he drank his warm milky early and
took a nap
i don't know nappy time was he loading
up on his caffeine so his brain could
function at a
halfway decent level we have no idea
whatever the case may be
i think it's obvious now to the entire
world why there's not going to be a
joint press conference
following tomorrow's summit with putin
the administration is scared to death
joe will deeply embarrass himself and
the country even further
and vladimir will take advantage of
joe's clear
cognitive weakness and constant state of
confusion
and of course are also concerned
surrounding zero experience hunter biden
yeah he's the guy that collected
millions of dollars from the first lady
of moscow that's right the mayor of
moscow's wife
and kazakhstan oligarchs and ukrainian
oligarchs
you know in the pro-russian oligarch who
owns barisma holdings in ukraine
again listen closely zero experience
hunter
made millions of dollars in ukraine no
relevant experience
whatsoever today joe announced ukraine
is too corrupt to join nato
but not corrupt enough for hunter to get
paid millions
take a look uh ukraine wants
a clear yes or no on getting into the
nato membership action plan
so what's your answer depends on whether
they meet the criteria
the fact is they still have to clean up
corruption the fact is they have to meet
other criteria
to get into the action plan and so it's
you know schools out on that question it
remains to be seen
let us get this straight joey sippy cup
okay
so ukraine's too corrupt for nato uh but
perfect for the biden family syndicate
zero experience hunter gets paid
millions any experience in oil gas
energy or ukraine
no uh imagine if a trump was doing this
and speaking of which hunter biden has a
new money-making scheme he just launched
a career as an
artiste apparently and despite zero
professional experience no art
degree hunter is now selling his
paintings at a top gallery in new york
city
expects to collect up to a half a
million dollars for each
masterpiece maybe we'll call it
portraits from a crack addict or
something
and of course according to the gallery
the buyers will all remain anonymous
oh who's trying to buy favor now should
make your skin crawl this might be the
biden family's most blatant pay-to-play
scheme yet
time will tell it is seedy it's
disgusting
and it's happening right in front of our
eyes but apparently when you're abiding
the rules don't apply to you
you can lie in a gun application you can
sell access to the highest levels
of our federal government you can smoke
crack you can abandon your own child
take away the child's mother's health
care if you're hunter
you can even say the n-word and in the
case of joe you could outright lie
on three occasions i've never talked to
hunter about his foreign business
dealings but we have pictures of him
dining as vice president with his
foreign business partners
so that's right if you're a biden you
can pretty much get away with anything
your doors are not going to be kicked in
pre-morning pre
early morning raid guns drawn you won't
have cnn cameras
capturing it all you're not going to get
interrogated for hours on end
you won't be threatened with decades
behind bars the media mob big tech
they'll always keep you in their biden
protection program they'll have your
back there'll be no investigations no
negative coverage
nothing the so-called journalists and
the press is more than happy to stick
their heads in the sand
while our country goes straight to hell
and shows nothing but weakness to the
world
just because they like joe's democratic
radical new green deal socialism
so tomorrow expect glowing praise from
the media mob
joe was tough with vladimir if he's so
tough of vladimir
why does he stand next to vladimir in
front of the world and say it right to
his face
and let us watch it but know this no
good is coming out of this
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else